is Nick Jonas TVs new secret weapon nine
million tuned in to watch his debut on
the voice of Stuart that's up from last
season's premiere the rookie coach
parachuted on set took a bit dramatic
stripped-down James Bond style is this
about to be a Magic Mike moment and went
head-to-head with Blake he even hopped
on stage for some real-time coaching to
seal the deal think about your posture
just standing a bit taller how is the
dynamic been with Blake Shelton because
back at the CMAs he he was pissed at you
because you essentially replaced his
girlfriend that's unacceptable we got to
settle this we're gonna settle this on
the stage coach to coach he's going down
I don't know I choose not to take
anything he says seriously good but I
think he was fine I think he you know as
long as he's got his cup full he's so
Howard went like doing now that they're
no longer coworkers the relationship is
going strong
Blake joined when on stage of her Vegas
residency to perform their duet nobody
but you
she gave him this giant hug as a
thank-you and then returned the favor
showing up at his concert the couple
tossed back a few shots backstage and
Gwen showed off her customized Blake
vans
[Music]